do you have let me let me let's figure
i'm curious like the type of groupies
everyone gets groupies when you have
this type of fame
what are your groupies like
um i got all kind of groupies i got like
weirdos
um i got uh
different [ __ ] trying to talk to me
you got a girl just says i'm pregnant
she's pregnant with my baby like wow a
girl said that yeah she was like i've
seen some like vlog [ __ ] like some girl
says i'm she pregnant with my kid did
you ever uh did you ever dabble in
females do you ever sleep with a woman
uh-huh um
during like high school so in high
school you were banging i had [ __ ]
um and so i only ever had sex with like
one girl like ever in my life okay
adjusted me like let me try justice
league let's give it a shot maybe i'm
tripping yeah like let me see it was it
was right now it was cool it was fun
it was fun
but it wasn't fun enough for you to keep
going
but it was like okay like you know
i see i see what you got going on you
know what i'm saying that's a macaroni
fan
[Laughter]
this was in high school yeah i was out
of high school already i was out of high
school shout out to you mm-hmm